here's the
punchline you know there are so many
people on Earth that follow the profile
of this gentleman where you're chasing
the cash which is why he had 50 you know
businesses prior to this of trying to
get rich and then finally when he
settled in and was all out of steam on
that model he focused on something he
wanted to do something he believed in
and lo and behold miraculously it's the
business that pops for him so many of
you actually can do it but if you're
chasing the next trend you're going to
get caught up if you take a step back
and actually build a business and do it
slowly around something you actually are
really into or really believe that is
the framework the blueprint that will
most work for most of you try
it